if you go back 150,000 years ago human
lifespan increased prodigiously in order
for us to have grandparents so that they
could watch over these children who were
utterly helpless learning how to be
adults and so it may be necessary to
incorporate Proto AIS in childlike
bodies and Foster them into human homes
so that they can do what our children do
in order to become intelligent and that
I believe could enable us to have a soft
Landing because we know how to do that
we know how to raise foster children to
love us I don't care if one of my foster
children is made of silicon and breathes
hard vacuum come back from mining
asteroids and take me fishing and tell
me the latest jokes when has that ever
happened to a grandparent